[Music]
and on the run news man on the run
submitted by la Cucaracha
how do you know that I will never know
but an executive at the largest Porsche
dealer in America vanished with 2.5
million in buyer deposit good job it was
like I'm out oh wait no buyer deposits
people trying to like they put the
Potter down payment down like the new
ones that are coming out like so there's
like really sought-after Porsches yep so
what people would do to it okay cool I
want to secure my spot because some
limited edition so these are what the
deposits are for oh that's not cool the
customer deposits they're saying that
they were for cars that never existed so
he was lying so he was lying to
customers so he sold them cars that
don't even exist they're kind of stupid
that's a good Sussman if you went to go
get a BMW and they were like you know
we'll look at this picture of this car
though like Porsche fanatic like big
collector like oh like a special special
like this [ __ ] isn't online exactly a
secret Club so they're saying that um
this dude Shiraz suka rally [ __ ]
Shiraz looks like he's named after a
wine I don't know oh that's the wrong
yeah this dude he's wanted VP of
Marketing
she's look good marketing specialist she
[ __ ] sold cars the BitFenix is 2.5
millions worth yep so he created a shell
company called champion auto ship oh so
first of all the the dealership where he
works where he's been working for the
last 10 years is called champion Porsche
and it's in Florida or Porsche or
however you pronounce it so he created a
shell company called champion Auto Sport
and that's where he produced fake
documents to trick to trick buyers into
thinking that they were placing a real
order with the dealer
and then he would then divert that money
into a secret bank account and then he
he just disappeared with all this money
he admitted to this in emails and phone
calls with championship Oh champion
Porsche but um but they don't know where
he is
what did he do that he just called yeah
I did it I mean I don't know that house
has reported that he did admit to it and
can you imagine but email hey shuri's uh
did you feel energy crisis response back
yes I did
by he's probably in the Dominican
Republic just chillin living his life
having his best life yeah what kind of
name is that like is that Middle Eastern
or like I don't know like he looks it's
so weird cuz he looks like a Indonesian
dude yeah I don't know what he is but um
but they do mention that he had
financial problems I can see why gamble
or dude it could have motivated this
crime because he had a lawsuit or the
lawsuit mentions American Express had
recently garnish his wages wages from
the dealership and that he had also been
struggling to pay child support for his
ten kids I don't know use a condom has
entities were good what if that 2.5
million just went all to them I'm sure
they would take it back yeah partial
take it back I know I hope so but
obviously this is a person with a
problem so I don't think she gave it to
his kids I'm a bit jealous because I
like to look at the brighter side in
life and he has ten kids and 2.5 million
dollars that's awesome so you think he's
gonna give it to his kids it's awesome
that he uses his kid
it's awesome man you [ __ ] over at
least like twenty four people because
there's no logic is they can afford a
Porsche it didn't hurt them exactly
right if they're fanatics their balling
on the brighter side
exactly no but not all of them what if
some of these people worked really
really hard to get their dream war I was
real
I feel sad for that one one poor guy
that saved up all this money for this
Porsche that never existed because he's
kind of dumb and I think if you're
saving all that money you're not gonna
be like a collector's item Porsche kind
of but you're gonna be like give me the
cheapest one so I could say I have a
Porsche most fanatics do not there are
there bawling yeah they have ten other
Porsche looks they got ripped off though
the principle yeah I agree I mean yeah
yeah but it's like hey if someone ripped
you off for $20 I'm not crying for you
that's what I mean it's only 24 these
people like they have 30 cars you know
they have all they have a truck just for
their car like do I like this person or
I hate this person because I feel like I
don't give a [ __ ] about the 20 but I'm
gonna make sure that you [ __ ] go down
that's awesome care about stranger I
don't care about that man I got a
[ __ ] loser is the main dealer gonna
or is Porsche like internationals gonna
try to refund any of that money or do it
that's the thing
so the dealership they're just they're
not talking at all they're just like we
didn't know anything about this but
what's shady so like for the lot of
people are angry at the dealership too
is because this whole was involved in a
lawsuit file so back in the summer of
2016 this other dealership and turned
into agreements to buy to $500,000
Porsche 911 ours so one was directly
from from the dealership through this
dude and then a second was from this
other entity which was this dude's shell
so it's like both through this dude and
then so the first car was never
delivered and then a results in like
this back and forth of that $350,000
deposit and then the second one was
delivered but there was a $350,000
markup and then so that dealership was
demanding for a refund and they were met
with a series of bad checks from this
dude which then led on to for this
lawsuit to be filed so they just
employed him even after he was
well that's the thing that's what a lot
of people are saying it's like [ __ ] you
champion Porsche you guys knew about his
shady [ __ ] because of this love it
already
like y'all teamed up and did shady [ __ ]
together and then they're like hurt like
who knows if he even worked alone like
you know I don't like him anymore
or he just took the fall I hope he's
spending his extra hours taking care of
kids in that partying way you liked him
I only heard 10 kids and 2.5 billion and
all the other things didn't really
register sending the money to the kids
great judge if they can't catch him for
this 2.5 million I doubt they can child
support can catch him here actual
services can probably not catch them
either no and they're also saying that a
lot of these fraudulent transactions
crossed state lines which means that
it's only a matter of time the FBI is
gonna get involved if they haven't
already
damn maybe that fool should have been
like a triathlete cuz he's good at
getting away but you have to have a
crazy amount of imagination and
confidence to pull [ __ ] like this cuz I
there's I can't even fathom like
thinking up a crazy ass scheme could you
I feel like you I probably can if I was
desperate I think desperate people
become very creative I think I can but I
also think I enjoy I think I enjoyed not
living stressful and always watching my
back yeah so I don't do that
but well cuz now we have something
called confidence he doesn't have much
confidence in that way people do crime
because like they're not confident to do
it in in the in the right way but that's
the only option yeah they just have to
it's like it's like people that play
games right like board games or whatever
and then they cheat because they don't
think they can win they can win toe to
toe like they feel like they could they
have to win by cheating same concept
that make sense or free on JK Party
third there's no winners you just spin a
wheel of Tory just get butt-fucked and
that's it Oh we'll make a competition
out of it not every single jkp okay I
know but I've been traumatized recently
yeah I don't understand that jkp yeah I
bet you if we were on that one we would
turn it into a win or lose situation by
being like who can do more of that well
Steve kind of turned it that way right
he was you guys yeah yeah tannaz wow
this guy needs to get caught
he said get beat I need to pay it over
you know how like the reality of
thieving and crime is actually like this
it's it's it's sad right it sucks but
then we also glorify the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] cuz it's crazy when someone
could get away with it like catch me if
you can that's fascinating
that guy learn like fooled doctors
lawyers
pilots like he flew planes that's crazy
and on top of on top of making fake
checks there's all these heist movies
yeah free internet so he was you went to
the library and he had to like look up
all the books in actual books like you
read books what's a library I know right
and not the kind that's on your Apple
iTunes that's all I know like the oceans
like rights like so cool and I'm like
yeah you know what I think I could steal
cuz like when smart people do crime it's
like yeah and then when dumb people do
crime well they don't show the ugly side
of that yeah you know like sometimes I
do like people getting shot because like
you [ __ ] this up like a lot of the
cartel ones I feel like are the ugly
side the ugly side of yeah well cuz
that's like they're like usually like
real like narcos or something like this
on a true story right
but like all these other ones where it's
like oh we're gonna have a Chinese guy
from the circus [ __ ] do a backflip
into this and then we're gonna have this
pickpocket yeah we should have like a
real Ocean's eleven gonna catch me if
you can was real it was real yeah guys
I'm a real true story I don't remember
that it's crazy you should watch it
against a movie okay so they're saying
that all these victims cuz at least 24
people fell victim to this they are
trying to find out like what the hell's
gonna happen with all the money I gave
they're gonna find out cuz you [ __ ]
with like 24 millionaires right they all
go
a lot of lawyers and then they're saying
that the the dealership has also lowered
up and they're just anybody that's angry
about this whole situation they're just
like here talk to the law firm I don't
know
so the law firm is saying that they will
no more on the re recompensing process
by the end of the month how much did
each person give as a deposit I'm not
sure it's just the total of 2.5 million
I hope you didn't mess with the Florida
drug lord it all varies because some
people put down deposits for cars Oh
like I want this one this one this one
and there's like here's a million is any
of that money I see I see insured since
its TechNet technically fraud I don't
know all right cuz it was an account I
mean that's something but that's the
only other $50,000 yeah as I was
wondering about that now
[Music]